to what extent do you think that there's
like real currency of having a
reputation as a police officer as
somebody who if you want to go there he
will go there or she will go there i
didn't come in here looking for a
reputation you know what i mean i didn't
come here thinking i want to be viewed
like this type of cop or person i'm not
perfect i've been a bad person i've done
some horrible things and i've tried my
best to make amends for that and i know
i'm going to be working on that [ __ ] for
the rest of my life this idea of kind of
like police reform and defunding the
police and all that like where do you
think that stuff is coming from agencies
in this country don't want cops like me
anymore they don't want that aggressive
cop i have a daughter if she's one years
old she'll be two in january
i'm gonna have to tell her like yo the
stuff that i do
a lot of it is a result of something not
just the pain i went through but the
pain i caused you have to be humble and
you're never going to get better if
you're always the best guy in the room
if you want to be happy you got to be
true you got to be authentic if you're
not that like faking it you'll always be
miserable the [ __ ] that i did as a
teenager in my early 20s is some [ __ ]
i'm gonna be trying to fix when i'm
[ __ ] 60 70 80 years old you know when
i think if you treat people right
whether they work for you they work
around you or you're policing them
they'll treat you right